à partir de mardi prochain les nouvelles
mesures concernant le financement de la
sécurité sociale seront appliquées il
s'agit vous le savez du relèvement des
cotisations pour les entreprises et pour
les salariés une sécurité sociale qui
n'est pas une invention française tous
les grands pays industrialisés dispose
de régime presque identique y compris
l'urss où il existe une sécurité sociale
pour les 270 millions d'habitants elle
est entièrement à la charge de l'état et
les soviétiques considère que c'est
l'une de leurs réussites les plus
spectaculaires regarde l enquête
réalisée en urss par françois go et par
une équipe de tf1
pour toute la population en urss les
soins médicaux sont gratuits les
médicaments aussi ou presque et le pays
compte le plus fort pourcentage de
médecins dans le monde
trente et un pour dix mille habitants
contre 16 pour 10000 à aux états unis
mais qui financent la sécurité sociale
eh bien il n'y a pas de cotisations
prélevées sur les salaires
il ya simplement des cotisations versées
par les entreprises auxquelles s'ajoute
le cas échéant un complément pris sur le
budget de l'état et les fonds de la
sécurité sociale sont gérés par les
syndicats tandis que leur usage est
contrôlé par les comités syndicaux
l'entreprise ya un grand club et ce type
qui à titre d'exemple sauve dire qu'en
nous avons assuré le repos avec tous les
soins médicaux appropriés à 489 mille
personnes et l'année dernière
lemay aux repos est assurée à 761
stimuli travailleurs politique de la
santé axée sur la prévention
chaque année plus de 7000 établissements
de cure préventorium et maisons de repos
accueille quelque 33 millions de
soviétiques
cependant il y a le revers de la
médaille médicaments rares équipements
hospitaliers désuet hôpitaux surpeuplés
et les médecins américains qui pendant
plusieurs mois on travaillait en urss
estime que les médecins soviétiques sont
moins qualifiés que leurs collègues
occidentaux médecine axée sur le
quartier où vivent les salariés et sur
l'entreprise où il travaille
pour les 450 salariés de la ferme d'état
qu'il dirige en georgie sur les bords de
la mer noire
cet homme a fait construire un
préventorium pourront savoir l'occasion
composée non seulement les oreillers lé
personnel d'offres aux mais aussi ceux
qui travaillent par exemple passe à côté
de nous médecine gratuite sans doute
médecine collective aussi en urss un
même groupe de médecins prend en charge
un même bloc de beaucoup d'acier